de nombreux contes étranges un outil de cette jungle
mais aucun aussi étrange que l'histoire du
petit que nous appelons Mowgli,
le livre de la jungle original, la version animée de 67
Disney était quelque chose
avec
laquelle j'ai grandi lorsque vous prenez un contenu et que
vous le mettez à jour, vous avez  pour être sûr qu'il
y a une raison à cela, ce qui nous
permet de faire ce film maintenant, c'est la
technologie pour avoir une animation photo d'animaux réels
Je suis un grand fan du
livre original c'est vraiment une écriture extraordinaire
c'était un sacré gars Kipling
alors quand Jon  Favreau a dit voudriez-
vous faire ça Je ne pouvais vraiment pas dire sans peur
danger humour et aussi émotionnel Je
voulais vraiment aborder ces sensibilités
je veux dire Mowgli il a dix ans il a
grandi dans la jungle ce sont deux
animaux différents mais  ils ont formé une
unité familiale
Shere Khan parle du chef de la
jungle est interdit et il se lance dans cette
poursuite mortelle
comme pour tous mes films, cela commence toujours
par le casting Je dois avoir un excellent
casting suis-je dans la bonne température de singe  le Je
pense que pour les performances vocales, l'astuce est
de les faire vraiment agir comme s'ils étaient
dans la saison du film Je peux me montrer
alors qu'ils commencent à voir l'animation et à
travailler les uns avec les autres, cela commence à
s'amuser
Mowgli aligne sa propre famille qui est  la
beauté de l'histoire qu'il crée ses propres
familles se présentent sous différentes formes
et tailles et c'est une histoire à laquelle
tout le monde se rapporte vous avez une bonne
histoire vous racontez tous ensemble les
bonnes choses arrivent